السلام عليكم ورحمه الله ابحث عن ايدي حزب
العمال الكردستاني تقولها تركيا في اغلب
الاحيان عندما تضربها تفجيرات في هذه
المدينه او تلك لم يشذ المسؤولون هذه
المره في توجيه اصابع اتهام للغريم
التقليدي حزب العمال الكردستاني في
التفجير المزدوج الذي وقع في اسطنبول مساء
السبت فمن غيره يسعى لزعزع امنها والعبث
باستقرارها ولم يطل انتظار الجواب حتى
اعلنت فعلا مجموعه المقربه من حزب العمال
تطلق على نفسها اسم سقور حريه كردستان ان
انها المسؤوله عن التفجيرين مراسل الجزيره
عامر لافي معنا من
اسطنبول عامر اين وصلت التحقيقات في تفجير
المزدوج الذي وقع امس في اسطنبول وهل
اتضحت الصوره
اكثر نعم عبد الصمد لازال الوضع كما هو
عليه هناك 13 من المعتقلين الان لدى قوات
الامن التركيه لم يتضح بعد لكن السلطات
التركيه اكدت او انها قالت بانه 9 بال حزب
العمال الكردستاني هو المسؤول عن هذا
الهجوم وانها لن تذيع ما لديها من تفاصيل
كثيره كما قالت حفاظا على سريه سير
التحقيقات في هذه القضيه لكن بغض النظر لا
شك ان ما جرى هذا الهجوم كان ضربه موجعه
وجاءت في وقت حرج بالنسبه لتركيا التي
تخوض الكثير من المعارك على جبهات مختلفه
داخليه
وخارجيه كانت مدينه اسطنبول التركيه على
موعد مع ليله عطله نهايه اسبوع داميه بعد
نحو سته اشهر من هدوء نسبي عاشته المدينه
التي يسكنها خمس سكان البلاد عشرات القتلى
والجرحى سقطوا جراء تفجيرين في محيط ملعب
نادي بشكتاش الاسطنبولي
الشهير اتهمت انقره حزب العمال
الكردستانيه بالوقوف ورائها وتوعدت
بالانتقام والتصميم على المضي في حربها
حتى القضاء على ما تسميه الارهاب بيد ان
هذه لم تكن المره الاولى التي تقدم فيها
انقره وعيدا كهذا حيث استمرت التفجيرات في
ضرب المدن التركيه ليصل عددها الى نحو 20
تفجيرا خلال العام الجاري وحده اتهم
بتنفيذها كل من حزب العمال الكردستاني
وتنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه وياتي هذا الهجوم في وقت تخض
فيه انقره حروبا على جبهات عده داخليه
وخارج
داخليا خاضت تركيا حربا ضروسا ضد العمال
الكردستاني في جنوب شرق البلاد منذ تموز
عام
2015 وتمكنت منتصف العام الجاري من افشال
مشروعه لاقامه مناطق حكم ذاتي في المدن
ذات الاغلبيه الكرديه فعاد الحزب الى
استهداف المراكز الامنيه والحيويه داخل
المدن خارجيا خاضت تركيا حربا سياسيه مع
شركائها الاوروبيين واتهمتهم بدعم
الارهابي والسماح لمناصري حزب العمال
الكردستاني بالعمل بحريه على اراضيهم
خصوصا انه يوجد في المانيا وحدها نحو 400
جمعيه ومنظمه مجتمع مدني مرتبطه بالحزب
كما يقول الاتراك ووصلت الازمه حد تصويت
البرلمان الاوروبي لصالح قرار غير ملزم
بوقف مفاوضات ضمام تركيا الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي كما توترت علاقات انقره مح
خليفتها واشنطن المتحالفه مع حزب الاتحاد
الديمقراطي في سوريا والذي لا ترى فيه
انقره سوى فرع سوري لحزب العمال
الكردستاني وعلى جبهه داخليه اخرى تخض
انقره حربا امنيه ضد عناصر ومؤيدي تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه واخرى تهدف الى استئصال
تنظيم فتح الله جولان الذي تتهمه بالوقوف
وراء المحاوله الانقلابيه الفاشله منتصف
تموز ي الماضي وعلى اثرها اعتقل او عزل من
وظائفهم الاف الجنود والموظفين من مختلف
مؤسسات الدوله اما خارجيا فالجيش التركي
وفي واحده من المرات القليله النادره في
تاريخ الجمهوريه يتدخل عسكريا بشكل مباشر
داخل الاراضي السوريه لتقديم الدعم الى
الجيش السوري الحر في حربه مع تنظيم
الدوله ولكي يحرم الاكراد من حلمهم في
تحقيق تواصل جغرافي بين مناطق نفوذهم في
شمال
سوريا عبد الصمد لا شك ان هذا الهجوم جاء
ليزيد من تعقيد المشهد التركي المعقد اصلا
ويطرح العديد من الاسئله عن مستقبل
السياسه الذي التي ستنتهي الحكومه التركيه
سياسيا وعسكريا وامنيا وعن السياسه التي
اتخذتها في الماضي عسكريا وسياسيا وامنيا
ايضا شكرا لك عامر لافي مراسل الجزيره في
اسطنبول اي ونرحب بضيفي الذين ض ينضمان
الينا من اسطنبول الدكتور جنكيز تومار
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جمعه مرمره
وبضيف من ميامي ميامي المحلل السياسي غيمي
بييه نرحب بضيفي
الكريمين استاذ دكتور جانكيز تومار المشهد
التركي مقد ويزداد تعقيدا ولكن في كل مره
تتعرض تركيا لتفجيرات كهذه او هجمات كهذه
تتوجه باصابع التهام فقط الى حزب العمال
الكردستاني
لماذا طبعا
هناك حزب الامال الكردستانيه
المشتبه
الاكثر شهره في تركيا والشيء الثاني
الداعش يعني وبالنسبه انما ننظر الى الشكل
التفكيرات
ومباشره الهدف الشرطه ونحن
ا نتوقع بان هذا العمليه هذه العمليه
الحزب الامال الكردستاني وايضا هناك
اي في بعض
ال الوكالات الانباء وهناك اخبار يعني ه
حزب الامال الكردستاني
او المنظمه تابعه لحزب الامال الكردستاني
اي هي المسؤوله عن هذه الانفجارات طبعا
هناك عده اسباب اي كما قال مراسلكم ر خاصه
هناك حرب شرسه جدا في جنوب تركيا وهذا
الحرب تقريبا و 30 اكثر من 30 سنه وحتى
الان 50 الف شخص قتلوا يعني
هذه السبب هذا السبب الاول وطبعا سبب
الثاني المشاكل في العراقيه في العراق
وسوريا لها تاثير كبير في المنطقه وخاصه
هذه الانفجارات في داخل تركيا وهناك يعني
رسائل عده من دول الكبيره وايضا استخبارات
الكبرى لتركيا بطريق هذه الانفجارات ايضا
ن وهذا وهذا ما اشار اليه اردوغان حينما
قال سننتصر على هؤلاء هذه التنظيمات
الارهابيه ومن يقف وراءها سيد غيمي بييه
حزب العمال الكردستاني لينفي مثل هذه
الاتهامات بل ان تنظيمات محسوبه عليه كما
يعني حدث اليوم عندما اعلنت مجموعه سقور
حريه كردستان مسؤوليتها عن التفجير
المزدوج امس في اسطنبول ولكن السؤال يبقى
هنا الا ترى الدول الغربيه ان التزامها
الصمت ااء مثل هذه الهجمات التي توصى
الارهابيه يعني امر يثير الحيره وربما
يجعل البعض يضعها في في محل
الشبهه
نعم
من من المرجح ان سقور حريه كردستان هم
الذين شنوا هاتين الهجم تين عاده عندما
تقوم داعش بهذه الهجمات تقوم بقتل
المدنيين لكن المنظمات التابعه لحزب
العمال كردستان ثاني تستهدف الشرطه والجيش
وعندما نتحدث عن الصمت من جانب الغرب
اعتقد ان هناك مبالغه
اعتقد الجامعه عفوا السفاره
الامريكيه في قطر اصدرت قرا بيانا ادانت ف
العمليه البرلمان الاوروبي بعث برساله
تضعون مع الشعب التركي اذا هناك بعض
البيانات الرسميه الواضحه نعم من حيث
التوقيت هذه العمليات تقع في مرحله حرجه
في مرحله انتقاليه بين خروج اداره اوباما
وتسلم اداره ترامب وهناك ايضا مساله
اختيار وترشيح وزير خارجيه وربما هذه
الاخبار لم تحتل مكان الصداره في الصحف
لكن هناك شعور تضامني في البلدان الغربيه
مع الشعب التركي دكتور جمار ذكر كت قبل
قليل بان تنظيم الدوله ايضا هو يعني موضوع
اتها موضع اتهام ايضا من انقره ولكن يبقى
في درجه اقل وان الحزب العمال الكردستاني
بحكم تاريخه تاريخ علاقاته المتوتره مع
الدوله التركيا هو الذي يبقى دائما في في
في الصداره صداره التهام لكن لماذا لا لا
تضع انقره في في الحسبان تنظيم الدوله
باعتباره خصما طالما هدد في الاونه
الاخيره وتوعد بمهاجمه تركيا واهداف حيويه
في تركيا وان تركيا على الارض السوريه
وجهت له ضربات قويه في الاونه الاخيره
خاصه في مدينه
الباب طبعا هناك بعض الادله في
الشرطه كما تفضل
ال مراسلكم
13 المعتقل موجوده الان وها هؤلاء اظن من
الاكراد يعني وتابع تابعون لحزب الامال
الكردستاني يعني هناك
فرق داعش يستعمل اما السوريين او الاتراك
في داخل تركيا ولكن حزب الامال
الكردستاني الارهابيين تاعبه لحزب الاماء
الكردستاني اكثرهم الاكرات يعني هناك فرق
وايضا الحزب الا الكردستاني يعني دائما
يستهدف الشرطه حتى عندهم سياسه الحزبيه
يعني حتى يكون يكون هناك مبررات يعني نحن
نقاتل ضد الجيش التركي او الشرطه التركيه
ليس
[موسيقى]
ل الناس العاديين
وهذا استذ دكتور جنكيز دكتور جنكيز وهذا
السؤال اذا كانت نعم اذا كانت تركيا دائما
ت
حب هذه الض كيف تنجح هذه العناصر التابعه
لحزب العمال او التشكيلات المواليه لها
كيف تنجح في تنفيذ عمليات بهذه الوتيره في
اماكن حساسه كهذه واستهداف الشرطه
بالتحديد طبعا
هناك تعرفون يعني الحزب الامال الكردستاني
ليس مثل داعش في تركيا داعش ليس له
دعم في داخل تركيا او الشعبيه في داخل
تركيا ولكن هزب الاعمال
الكردستاني له عناصر خاصه في المدن الكبرى
وايضا في جنوب تركيا يعني من الذي يشجع
ويدعم الافكار حزب الامال
الكردستاني
من المواطنين التركيين الشيء الثاني انا
اتوقع ال حزب الامال
الكردستاني متشجع من قبل الاوروبيين ايضا
ونحن نعرف الكثير من المنظمات
الموجوده في اوروبا وهناك
استخبارات المراكز الاستخبارات او
المؤسسات الاستخباراتيه
الاوروبيه تدعم هذه المنظمه يعني
هناك سؤ استاذ دتور هذا السؤال الكبير
يعني هنا لوجه للسيد ريمي بييني كيف توفق
هذه الدول الغربيه بين محاربه الارهاب من
جهه وبين تجاهل او دعم كما قال ضيفنا في
اسطنبول حزب العمال الكردستاني الذي ينفذ
مثله مثل هذه الهجمات التي تبقى بشكلها
وبطريقه تنفيذها والاهداف التي تضعها
دائما في هذه العمليه الهجمات تبقى يعني
ضمن ما يوصف بالارهاب لماذا
تستثني الدول الغربيه تزورها ودعمها للدول
المهاجمه المهاجمه من الارهاب الا تركيا
تستثني تركيا من
ذلك اولا علينا ان نركز على قضيه ان البيي
كي ينظر اليه كمنظمه ارهابيه حزب العمال
الكردستاني في اوروبا وفي الولايات
المتحده اذا هناك ادان رسميه لحزب العمال
الكردستاني لكن من جهه اخرى ما قاله
الزميل الضيف الاخر صحيح تماما ان
الارهابيون العائدون الى حزب الاعمال
الكردستاني هم من الداخل والعائدون لتنظيم
الدوله هم من الخارج لذلك هذا شان داخلي
تركي لكن مع ذلك هناك تبادل المعلومات
الاستخباريه بين الدول الغربيه و بين تركي
اردوغان قال ان هناك قنوات تمويل تاتي من
المانيا ومن بلجيكا تخضع لتحقيق الان
لكنني لن اقول ان هناك تاييد رسمي من
الدول الغربيه هذا سيكون خطا فادحا واضحا
لكن ايضا من المهم للدول الاوروبيه ان
يكون لديها معلومات استخباريه لقضيه تم
داخل تركيا اذا هذا امر صعب للبلدان
الاوروبيه او للولايات المتحده ان تكون
قادره على جمع معلومات بهذا الاتجاه بينما
الاسهل جمع المعلومات عن داعش من الخارج
اشكرك سيد ريمي بييه المحلل السياسي من
ميامي ومن سطبو نشكر الدكتور جنكيس تومار
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه
مرمره دول اوبك ومنافساتها في اسواق النفط
تحت سقف واحد في فينا الزميله غاد عويس
تتناول في الملف الثالث اتفاق منتج الن من
اوبك وخارجها على خفض الانتاج بدء من
الشهر المقبل